Privacy actually is not a new problem.
We have had it forever.
Now people have always worried
about what others know.
Others could be your friends,
could be your family,
could be your adversaries,
your competition.
It could be government agencies
when we talk about Big Brother,
when we talk about the government.
So what do they know about us,
in particular our activities and
what we do, or who we are?
So we always have worried about this.
So what's new in the online context?
Well the scale and
magnitude at which information about
what we do can be collected, okay?
Our activities online and someone's
ability to collect information about
what we do, and
then be able to share it and use it, and
even sold, sold for and
monetize that information.
The scale at which this can
be done now is unprecedented.